I really hope this doesn't start a big
fight or a flame war but just know that
if I have to I can defend myself okay so
I need to address something that I kept
seeing come up in the comments on the
video that I made about the possible
future of Star Wars as a franchise and
this is the first of what I'm gonna say
this has potential to become an
occasional series because every now and
then things go on in my comments section
that I find myself going wait what
and what I've started doing and I
actually started doing even before this
but what I've started doing is
requesting citations when I see people
bringing up things that like I've never
heard of and can't seem to find through
Google and and in this case it was in
reference to things said by Kathleen
Kennedy and other Lucasfilm associated
people because there were more than a
few people in the comments section of
that video who made reference or went on
lengthy diatribes talking about how
Kathleen Kennedy specifically and
Lucasfilm in general and sometimes
calling out some of the other dora as
some of the other people like JJ Abrams
or Rian Johnson have been actively
insulting the fanbase calling them well
actually you know what I'm gonna read
you some direct quotes because I've
started taking notes when I deal in what
people say because for you know I'm I'm
not great at a lot of things there are
plenty of things I'm prepared to shoot
at the hip from but when it comes to
talking about what people said I kind of
want to use their exact words I want to
be careful about that so here are some
examples of some things that I'm talking
about they meaning Kathleen Kennedy JJ
Abrams Rian Johnson called fans racists
anti a female and homophobes I am gonna
like adjust for grammar on some of these
so forgive me for that both directors
and Kennedy called anyone who didn't
like the
last Jedi racist and sexist Kathleen
Kennedy mandated gender politics to be
forced into the film Lucasfilm said
people who didn't love episode 8 are all
trite racist sexist they call people who
disagree with the direction racist
sexist man babies you'll notice a
recurring theme there of calling
basically people who were dissenting
head dissenting opinions on the last
couple of Star Wars movies out as bigots
and being dismissive of them and
initially when I saw that it was Bree it
was being brought up so often and so
casually as if this was just a well
understood fact that initially when I
started planning to do this video what I
thought it was gonna be about was about
just fan mishandling which is a topic
I've touched on a couple of times
recently it came up when talking about
the whole channel awesome thing because
ultimately you know a big part of what
caused the mess was the response to
things or I've also brought up in
regards to Star Wars before although it
was in terms of managing fan expectation
as opposed to something like this also
it's something that I actually have seen
happen before and that I I actually have
seen direct instances of you know in the
past but I'll sort of come back to that
in a minute
so it made sense and I just went about
thinking well you know I think it's
worth talking about the ways in which
people get goaded and get goaded or
prompted by questions to say things that
end up hurting them their brand their
franchise whatever and to talk about
that that's what I thought I was gonna
do but when I tried to source these
quotes I couldn't find them now let me
say up front I am not the world's best
researcher if you know anything about me
I actually avoid research like the
plague if I can help it at all
I don't enjoy doing it I'm not great at
it so I am open to the possibility that
my Google foo was not up to the task and
actually with that in mind I went a few
steps beyond I was actually requesting
citations from these comments and of the
various comments that I read you as well
as some others
only two people responded to that most
people gave no response to my request
for citation one of those respond EES
was very impassioned they didn't
ultimately give me a citation a source
somewhere that I could go to as the root
of these quotes one person provided
actually probably five or six things but
more than half of those were actually
think pieces written by folks who were
not directly involved in the making of
these films and that's another thing I
want to be distinct you know I don't
need any help in finding think pieces
punditry fan on fan you know of people
calling folks with issues with either
the last Jedi or solo or the fourth ways
or whatever calling people who didn't
like that racist sexist whatever I can
find that on my own
that I can find it's not other people
talking about it that I have any
interesting because I know that exists
its quotes from the people actually
involved because that that was what
interests me and I and again I thought I
was going to be talking about how people
just aren't properly managing you know
the PR related to the stuff that they're
in charge of but again I couldn't find
this so I even went so far as to put the
call out on Twitter like can anybody
cite me sources on this and what I came
away with ultimately with all of this
was two articles one picture and one
tweet that I think are in some way at
least worth touching upon that's
actually not a lot and now can I find a
ton of articles
referencing these same things yeah I can
find a fair number of those and again
mostly think pieces that's not much like
for how much people are saying that you
are or at least are behaving as if this
is so obvious that's not a lot of
concrete evidence at least that I had
been able to find and and if in response
to this I get given citations to
a ton of things that are beyond what I
was able to find or source that makes
that changes my perspective I will
immediately turn around and make a
follow-up video on what I originally
said this was intended to be but I
couldn't find the evidence to back it up
so instead I'm gonna talk about just the
way in which these things are being
blown out of proportion I don't think
are necessarily being questioned even by
people who may not be automatically
inherently inclined to believe them
because I mean I think we've probably
all heard the term confirmation bias at
this point in the last couple years
especially in regards to you know things
that get pushed on social media when you
see an article headline because let's be
honest most of us read headlines and
maybe skim the body but even if you read
the whole thing when you see an article
on something that backs up a belief you
already hold you're less inclined to
question that source you're less
inclined to go wait a minute have I ever
heard of this site before where are they
getting this information if it confirms
something you already believe that's
human nature that's not I mean I do that
we all do that so I think at least to a
certain degree that's kind of what's
going on here because these few things
and I am going to address them in
specifics that get brought up seem to be
reference to as bigger than what at
least to my eye they appear to be and
then that just snowballs as its own
thing and you hear it said and you go oh
man I can't believe she said that I knew
she was like that and it confirms
something you thought so you and then it
just spreads further it goes viral in
the bad way it is funny to me that going
viral as some as sometimes a desired
thing viruses are good we do understand
that right that's me getting hung up on
semantics now so here's what I was able
to find in terms of specific things that
actually said and I you know my thanks
to the people who did respond to me with
things - with citations with things that
I actually could reference that were
sources so here's what I've got one of
the big ones was from Indy wire and this
was in February of this year now I'm
gonna read you the headline cuz I'm
actually well I'll read it a headline
and then I'll say this headline is JJ
Abrams Star Wars fans who don't like
last Jedi are threatened by women
characters exclusive
I don't know indieWIRE I mean I know
Indy why he's been around for a while
not questioning them legitimately I
don't know if they have a tendency you
know towards sensationalizing headlines
and whatnot but that for what he
actually said is a sensationalized title
and I do think a misleading title
because it the the title of the article
is speaking in as in declarative terms
it's speaking as if this is what he said
his words as the title of this article
would have to say is fans who didn't
like last Jedi are threatened by women
characters here's what he actually said
if you are someone who feels threatened
by women and needs to lash out against
them you can probably find an enemy in
Star Wars his statement has the
component parts of what the title of the
article was but isn't really saying the
same thing it's saying if you do feel
threatened then you won't like this film
but the title claims the inverse that he
said if you don't like this film then
you will then you must feel threatened
and that's not saying it one way doesn't
make it true the other it's the inverse
property you know that I live I live in
Vermont the state of Vermont is in the
United States all Vermonters are
Americans
but the inverse is not true not all
Americans are Vermonters you know it's
base it's that basic and the way in
which he phrased it matters the way he
phrased it was if this is an issue for
you already then you will see something
to hate in these films not if you hate
these films this is your issue so that
that one I again I'm actually I'm
actually gonna blame indieWIRE for that
that's not even necessarily a cake well
I think possibly it is a case of people
reading the article and blowing and you
know taking the words out of context
selectively or whatever but the article
itself honestly that's a that's a really
sensationalized galvanizing polarizing
title and shame on them for it if I'm
being blunt now again if you still want
to say that you feel that his words and
his sentiment are indicative of a
mentality that you disagree with that's
one thing but what he said isn't even
what the title of the article claims
that he said so that's one next up is a
quote from Kathleen Kennedy now the
source I've got on this is New York
Times which I believe is the original
article and this is from this is from
before rogue one was released so this is
back in 2016 so this is going back aways
and actually I've been looking for these
things I did find several articles
basically stating how Kathleen Kennedy
was not directly engaging in responses
to you know a lot of the backlash and
and the things being said about her and
the films that she was producing that
was actually a theme that kept coming up
and given that the only thing that I
could find that actually has her own
words and it is from 2016 that kind of
backs it up so I don't think she's I
mean whatever it is you feel that she
believes or has been saying she doesn't
seem to be saying it very often but here
is what she said now this was in regards
to whether or not she feels the need to
placate the critics of the moves going
on with Star Wars and the nature the
quite
you know does kind of lead things
towards the question of well you keep
putting female leads in these things
because this was again this was a head
of rogue one so force awakened and sad
already happened so we had Ray and then
we got Jenner so so what she said
there's sort of two parts to this first
thing she said was I have a
responsibility to the company that I
work with I don't feel that I have a
responsibility to cater in some way and
to be fair that is at the very least
factually accurate ultimately she is
beholden to whoever writes her paycheck
now you can certainly say in a
roundabout way that that is the fans
because the fans make the money that
make the you know investors and
stockholders and people above her have
it be worth anything and so but like
directly saying you know who she's
actually answering to so now second part
and this is the one that I think
probably ruffled feathers she said I
would never just seize on saying well
this is a franchise that's appealing
primarily to men for many many years and
therefore I owe men something now
honestly the the wording on that
statement is a little weird I had to
like read it and reread a couple times
to sort of be like wait what is she
actually saying but but the first thing
to note is she's sort of putting she's
putting out a quote of I this is
something I wouldn't do but the the way
that this got recontextualized for a lot
of write-ups and think pieces is that
Kathleen Kennedy feels she doesn't owe
the fans anything which isn't quite what
she said and this one she obviously was
addressing something specifically in
terms of question of about what some
fans feel about these films in terms of
what they think about the the way in
which male characters are utilized in
the prominence of female characters and
at least my read on it the point that I
think she was trying to make and again
this is now me interpreting so obviously
you know some people have interpreted
this way my take on it is what she was
trying to say was I I'm expanding it out
I'm not I'm not going to continue to
just feed it to the same audience that
it's been primarily fed at and and I am
open to the possibility that I am
incorrect about that and even if I am
correct about that she could have worded
it better the way she worded it was a
little bit more I don't know it not
combatives the wrong word cuz it wasn't
even but really what it breaks down to
what she's saying is either I'm not
obligated to do this the way it should
it's been done up to this point although
her wording is easily construed in a way
that added fuel to this fire but it's
not the open antagonism that I seems to
be getting evoked by people who were
bringing this stuff up at the constant
and the comments so that's those are the
two those are the two and only two
articles that I was able to find in
addition to that there is the often
cited picture this one of Kathleen
Kennedy and several other women wearing
a shirt that says the forces female this
thing oh boy okay the forces female is
not a lucasfilm thing the forces female
is a Nike marketing campaign aimed
around the idea of women of just female
strength and she was not the only one
wearing it there she was not the there
were plenty of people not associated the
star was wearing it there where it was
being worn was not a Star Wars event it
was an event in relation to women
empowerment in business and things of
that nature that she was invited to so
she was one of unfairly large number of
people who were wearing that shirt that
shirt was not made for the purposes of
antagonizing Star Wars fans it exists
from
Nike campaign that is its own thing and
and that campaign does not have a Star
Wars tie-in so we're clear as well and
so that one I think that one more than
any is really a jumping on and ignoring
context because you show that image I
mean if you are if a narrative already
exists that this woman is pushing a
certain view of this franchise a
feminist view of this franchise and you
look at that image you go well that's it
but there's context to that image and
why it exists that seems to get ignored
pretty much completely and initially
when I saw that image because I knew it
was a Nike campaign a mission when I saw
that image I did think wow she maybe she
still should have thought better than to
wear it but thinking on it like it
wasn't even a Star Wars like event it
wasn't like she showed up to the
premiere or a promotional tour for the
franchise wearing that and so it that
one really does feel like a cherry pick
again other people may ascribe more
value to that than I do
other people have clearly but again
these are the only things I was able to
find so the last thing because somebody
cited a recent tweet from John Kasdan
now John Caston was one of the two
writers on solo and I've also talked
about him before because he was the one
who claimed that Lando was pansexual and
that was something that well kind of set
me off if you haven't seen my video on
queerbaiting that came up that was the
first thing that came up so mm-hmm yeah
I kind of do already have feelings about
this guy but here's what he tweeted this
is from the 18th of May this month woody
and this would have been before the
release of the film and what he tweeted
was sorry to have
brought identity gender politics into
nope not sorry at all because I think
galaxy
I think the galaxy George Lucas gave
birth to in 77 is big enough for
everyone straight black white brown
twi'lek solution wookie droid and
anything in between hashtag draw writes
hashtag we are sentient so I'm not gonna
rehash my feelings about his original
claim that Lando is pansexual he's not
it is vaguely hinted at at best by a
character that in context I have no
reason to give any belief to her words
but setting that aside because I don't
need to go down that rabbit hole again
the tweet is him saying he's not sorry
because he believes Star Wars is for
everyone and at worst like the tone of
starting to go I'm sorry nope like
that's a little it's dickish even seems
like too strong a word I mean that's
that's slightly antagonistic I suppose
just like yeah I can't think of a softer
word it's not harsh but the actual
message of that tweet is this is for
everyone and I had and I tried to
include more people than already were
currently included with this and he did
specifically say white as well it's not
like when he listed the people that this
is for he excluded white or he or that
he excluded well you actually didn't
cite gender at all he said straight gay
black white he didn't say men or women
so he didn't even touch on gender there
but he he said straight and he said
white so that's all I've found for the
again just judging by the way people
throw it out there seeming mountain of
evidence that Kathleen Kennedy is
mandating these inclusions that the
directors are pushing them and insulting
people who don't like their films these
are the only instances I can find okay
gonna jump in here real
quick because basically one other thing
was brought to my attention between when
I shot this video and when I was editing
it and it's something that I honestly
don't again it has a lot of substance to
it but it is about as relevant as the
other stuff that I found so I'm gonna
talk about it really quick because this
thing's long enough as it is there was a
tweet from Rian Johnson this was back in
February and his exact tweet was I and
I'll give the full context for a second
but the tweet was and I'm sure this is
something that's come up because it's an
actual word that I saw used that people
saying that this was something Lucasfilm
people were calling fans
he said don't feed the man babies now
that is something he said and that is a
word he said context which matters let's
remember the context on that is that
there was a tweet put out by a twitter
user called geek girl diva
who is not a Twitter user I know she's
but I don't have I don't really do
Twitter properly if we're being honest
but she had put out an image of Carrie
Fisher and said that she felt that the
last yet I was a love letter to Carrie
and you know I think a lot of us
regardless of how we feel about that
film were still feeling the loss of her
and that was very clearly what she was
expressing in that tweet and there was
another user who came in and basically
started getting snarky about it and
dropping Mary Poppins references right
off the bat now again what do you like
how Leia was handled in that film or not
that that at least that to me reads
isn't appropriate because it was very
much it was clear she was putting out a
heartfelt message that's not really the
forum or the outlet to air your
grievances about the the scene of her
force pulling yourself back from space I
mean that's that that's like showing up
at somebody's funeral and going yeah but
he kicked me in the nuts one time like
dude at the top of the place like Br
I mean that's time except I'm
exaggerating a little but that's the
vibe that I got off this and she did
engage with this guy there was a
back-and-forth between them so Ryan
Johnson saying don't feed the man babies
was actually not a general statement
about fans it was about one spell it was
basically it was him saying don't feed
the trolls but it was and even though it
says man babies plural which it seems to
be what everyone is running with he was
referring to one specific guy that
ignited him to say that so yes it was a
term that has been used once by one
person in reference to a specific
incident with a specific fan who I'm
sorry was kind of being a jerk
so and the other thing is because I I
fail to mention this later on because I
said I'm editing this thing right now um
god I'm rambling too much
okay the the thing is is that I keep
seeing people cuz more comments like
this have shown up on my videos while
I've been editing saying you know
Kathleen Kennedy's been insulting people
she's calling people names she's calm
people like they keep saying her name
and calling people names regardless of
whether or not you want to take this
quote from Ryan Johnson as name-calling
or even if you want to over extrapolate
out of what JJ Abrams said or any of
that Kathleen Kennedy hasn't called
anybody names the worst thing that you
can say is depending on your
interpretation of her lying about her
that she doesn't feel she needs to
pander to anybody that's about the only
thing with any meat on it but she
doesn't call anybody names in that so
dudes people had people if have been
called names mostly by other fans she
hasn't called anybody names not that I
can find again back to the original
schedule thing and even if you want to
ascribe more value to these than I do
which you know you interpret them as you
will
that's for solid source citations that I
could find since any degree of
controversy started up I would say I
guess in the wake of the first trailer
for the force awakens when we first saw
Finn because let's be honest that was
when there was initially
a stirring of some resent and resentment
and some questioning of agenda and
politics and whatnot that was 2015 I
think so in the last three years I found
four things from three different people
that again to my reading don't carry a
lot of vitriol or clearly have been
taken out of context and the thing is
when looking into you know the questions
of backlash and whatnot Kathleen Kennedy
is actually getting more substantive
criticism from the people that at least
the folks making these sorts of claims
of my comments probably think have her
back which is she keeps getting called
out for the fact that every single
director that has been hired so far to
work on Star Wars whether it be for the
for the movies or to start working on TV
projects under her watch has been a
white male and that isn't even a
criticism that's being made in a vacuum
because she herself said back in 2015
that she would love to have women
involved at that creative level so she
herself brought it up but then hasn't
delivered on it so it's funny for me
that I ended up finding honestly a lot
more support for that as a criticism of
Kathleen Kennedy that she is talking up
inclusion but not backing it up when it
comes to hiring directors which is
something that she herself specifically
cited she wanted to do so that I like
I'm not saying that that counterbalance
is any other argument any anybody wants
to make I just found that really kind of
curious and interesting now I did
mention that part of the reason I
initially inclined to think that I was
going to find evidence for this was
because it has happened before and it
has it happened in 2016 with
ghostbusters because when there was the
outcry against that film at least a
portion of which was motivated by no no
I'll back up I'm not because it was
motivated by sexism but was absolutely
certainly treading in the language and
the mentality of sexism and misogyny
whether you want to argue that that was
the root cause of some of the criticism
or not you cannot deny that some of the
criticism was absolutely making use of
that kind of rhetoric they when when I
say they I mean the the actors the crew
the director of the studio very much
actively pushed back against it called
it out you know in response they put it
they put out a cast picture with them
holding up girl power Kevin Feige was
very you know directly pushing back
against these people and and that I can
find citations and sources for and and
it's something that even he himself in
the year census said he probably would
it probably would have been better to
just not engage because all he did was
fuel the fire and fuel the flames and
also cause what I thought I was going to
be talking about in this video when I
started which was the fact that when you
get spurred to action through anger you
have a tendency to lump people together
in a way that makes things worse for you
and in that case there was a lumping
together of all criticism pre-release of
the film as being motivated by sexism
and speaking of someone who was critical
of the film but the fact that they were
women was never my problem with it it
was really frustrating to see not only
think pieces but also people associated
with the film appearing to conflate all
criticism with coming from sexist
sources and quote-unquote haters and
that is frustrating and that can turn
people who are on the fence or maybe
even inclined to be on your side against
you because they
they feel dismissed and marginalized by
you so that can happen that has happened
and I'm pretty sure actually that
Kathleen Kennedy and the other folks
noticed that that happened and that's
probably why at least so far as I'm able
to tell they're not talking about these
things actively they are occasionally
responding to questions being posed in
interviews and what I say occasionally I
mean like once a year and then those few
words are being used like smoking guns
that I just I don't think they are so I
don't want I don't want people to come
away thinking my point in this was to
totally dismantle this argument and go
and therefore it's absolutely not true
but I beg cuz that's not what I'm trying
to do here now I don't want this to come
across like it's me going checkmate
because I don't have that attitude I'm
just a guy trying to figure out what is
going on and a fandom that seems to be
losing its freaking mind
on all sides of this divide and it's not
fun for me so me diving down this rabbit
hole is just me trying to figure out
what is going on and what is this stuff
built off of and again to my I doesn't
seem to be built off of much but it has
erupted into this huge thing that and
again has people not people associated
directly with the film's but does have
people going you you guys who hate this
movie are all sexist or misogynist or
racist or whatever I know people are
saying that but they're not Kathleen
Kennedy they're not JJ Abrams they're
not Rian Johnson and these things that
people who are believed to be on their
side those things those people are
saying is being ascribed to what these
folks actually make the films were
saying and you need to be careful about
that and I'm not expecting this video to
change anybody's
mind at this point I think people's
beliefs and stances and positions
they've taken are pretty embedded so
you're gonna believe what you want to
believe what I would ask in the name of
sanity is check the sources actually
especially check the sources on
something that seems to confirm a belief
for you because it's a weird thing to be
so certain of something and then go
looking for the evidence and not finding
it that's a weird sensation and I think
it would behoove more of us to go
through that because fan star wars
phantom right now is not something I'm
proud to be a part of and and I'm saying
that because of the way people are
behaving and the level of vitriol being
thrown about and I'm not saying that you
have to support or you should hate or
you should be supporting these films or
you should hate these films or let you
do whatever you're gonna do but except
that other people are gonna do the other
option and that's not really affecting
you you know make your decision for
yourself for whatever reason if you want
to make the conclusion that you will not
see these movies again that is the
conclusion you have come to other people
may come to the conclusion that they
want to continue to see these movies or
that they're even now going to more
actively support them because of things
that they believe about the message or
the or whatever else and that is their
choice to make
people are making different choices that
is what people do so I don't know if
this video is gonna have a calming
influence or if I just kicked a massive
hornet's nest in any case whatever your
thoughts are please respectfully at this
point it's really weird to me that I
have to more actively curate and
moderate the comments section on a Star
Wars video than I do on a video about
queerbaiting yeah just whatever you
whatever your thoughts are please
express them respectfully even if you
don't agree with me even if you want to
give me more examples that you feel I
missed or whatever if you want to sign
me more things
fine I'm hoping that I encourage that I
want to see these sources but please no
personal attacks against me against the
people involved in this in these films
or against the people who are on the
other side of this argument whatever
side you're on just no personal attacks
because that's what will get me to
remove comments and I don't like having
to do it I don't like having to do it at
all I really don't have like having to
do it as actively as I've had to this
past week so if you can keep it civil
drop your comments down down below and
let's talk about it cuz I do want you
talking about this stuff there's also
all that stuff that you can do such as
support me on patreon like subscribe and
all those things links for all that
stuff's down in the description until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]